they laughing in his fight one guy come
all down with his bare hands
turn around mister you see ants slowly
aggravated assault is a felony in this
state mr. Reacher processed him and get
him to County
two things are gonna happen in the next
90 seconds excuse me
first that phone over there there's
gonna ring second you're gonna be
wearing these cuffs on your way to
prison well that is one magnificent
prophecy
mr. Reacher just gonna keep on ringing
when are you coming to DC I move around
a lot
you're a legend folks wonder why you
left Purple Heart Silver Star there's
this big dent and the dust people say
you made it with someone's putter that
creature from agent Turner major
Turner's been arrested on what charge
espionage
he'd been set up how much does Regent
know how's it going I don't like being
followed you think you're a vulnerable
that's right
maybe I rip your arm off beat you to
death with it I'm sorry
feature you here to kill you
my men were shot by one of our own this
is bigger than I imagined you ever lose
anyone on your watch Reacher
you're a dead man
you think you're above the law
I'm not the law so you should start
running because I'm gonna start hunting
and when I find you I'm gonna kill you
all
it's a haircut
all you guys go to the same barber
you